Many of the most important questions in public
policy are quantitative by nature, and government
organizations such as the Joint Committee
on Taxation and the Congressional Budget Office
spend tens of millions of dollars developing
computational simulation models to address
those questions. As tax reform heats up, the
JCT will predict the revenue and macroeconomic
effects of competing proposals to guide Congress
and the public.
The CBO has had their share of the limelight
estimating the insurance coverage and budgetary
effects of health care reform.
The problem is, the models these teams develop
are not available to the public. This undermines
the free competition of ideas because the
public can't use the models to develop creative,
new proposals.
This undermines the predictive accuracy of
the models, because their creators can’t
participate fully in the scientific community.
And it undermines trust in government, because
how can the public trust that which resides
behind a curtain?
Congress could mandate that researchers in
government share all of their work openly,
and we would have better tax policy, better
spending policy, and a healthier democracy.